tja wie können wir unsere kinder
schützen darüber spreche ich jetzt mit
dem schwimmlehrer alexander service vom
verein aqua kids in berlin
ja was geht ihnen als schwimmlehrer
durch den kopf wenn sie da von diesen
vielen unfällen haben also traurigkeit
aber auch die chance nutzen und ärger
besetzen weil ich der meinung bin dass
ein oder andere hätte man sicher dass
durch ausweichen können wir haben
einfach momentan die problematik dass
auch in den vergangen jahren viele sind
schon wieder geschlossen worden sind und
somit auch nicht so einfach zu wenig
wasser flächen vorhanden sind unmöglich
den kindern beibringen
es wurde schon mehrfach in dieser
sendung gesagt zu wenig kinder lernen
das schwimmen und können wenn man sie
sprachen die geschlossenen schuhen an
woran liegt das nach nehmen da auch die
für eltern ihrer verantwortung nicht
ganz wahr
das ist auch ein großer punkt den wir
bei uns im kreis stellen dass viele
eltern teilen wir es auch gar nicht sein
können und das thema schlimm auch gar
nicht so ganz lieben diese natürlich
dann auch der meinung dass es
ausreichend ist das liedchen zu machen
was überhaupt nicht dabei ist sie
püppchen bedeutet die dich man kann sich
mit ihm über wasser halten
das problem das wir eigentlich haben bei
den kindern ins ziel einfach nicht mit
kondition haben länger schon zu können
und damit eben richtig schwimmen lernen
ja was können eltern tun wenn sie mit
ihren kindern schwimmen gehen wir haben
auch jetzt in dieser sendung öfter
gehört viele verlassen sich darauf mit
schwimmflügeln sich das wasser man kann
stehen da wird schon nichts passieren
das ist also ganz komplett verkehrt hier
sehr gefährlich seit ich das wasser
heißt auch nicht dass wir die gefahren
sind gerade mal bei seichten gewässern
oder ruhigen gewässern
nehmen wir die frage ob minister kann
eine gute gekommen
da können morath schlamm stadt dort vor
ort zu sein und dadurch natürlich sehr
sehr groß die gefahr dass da was
passiert
schwimmflügel alleine bringen
und gar nichts zum eigentlich nur
unterstützend tätig und sollten auch nur
davon verwendet werden
wie auch schon der kollege von der
realität und angesprochen hat es ist
sehr wichtig dass die kinder schwimmen
lernen und zwar richtig schon danone auf
diese prüfen ständig zu betreiben zu
müssen dass es ja auch selbst kinder die
schon schwimmen können man hat fast den
eindruck im meer gibt es strömungen er
die badeseen sind nicht sicher empfehlen
sie überhaupt noch das schwimmen in
naturgewässern oder sollte man sich
lieber in ein schwimmer zurückziehen wo
auch immer ein bademeister vor ort ist
also ich würde innere immer irgendwie
bayerischen schulen gegeben
darauf arbeiten in der regel nur
qualifizierte menschen die speziell
darauf trainiert sind gerade bei kindern
kindern das spricht diese stummen
beizubringen und im schwimmbad ist es
natürlich super haben wir ja ganz andere
voraussetzungen wir haben nicht die
wassertemperatur her haben wir einen
beckenboden die marien krank man kann
sich also dort sehr gut auch in ihren
platz im natur gewehrt haben überhaupt
nicht der fall ist jetzt haben ja corona
bedingt viele schwimmbäder dazu und auch
viele kurse können nicht stattfinden sie
unterrichten ja sonst kinder finden ihre
kurse denn in berlin statt
ja wir haben leider das problem dass wir
im eigenen garten haus eingemietet sind
und aufgrund der aktuellen ko-runde
gegen die mobiltelefonie stoppen lassen
eine letzte frage noch an sie empfehlen
sie denn eltern ihren kindern selbst das
schwimmen beizubringen oder sollte das
immer in einem professionellen umfeld
stattfinden
die frage die wir zu beantworten als
nicht so wenn eltern gegen die immer
schon können kamera zu suchen die über
den weg über im juni 6 an der sorge
vielen herzlichen dank dann hoffen wir
dass alle kurse bald wieder stattfinden
können damit wir dort unsere kinder auch
richtig vorbereiten können danke ihnen
für das gespräch